Careful!
This video contains manga spoilers!
The moment the 8 year old Momo sacrificed
his childhood to transform into a full grown
dragon and face his greatest fears head on
in order to save his country, I knew that
we had just witnessed the climax of one of
the best character arcs in the One Piece.
What an incredible turnaround for the traumatized
and mistrusting little kid Luffy found in
the depths of Punk Hazard, whom he then turned
into a full-fledged leader in a matter of
months.
Being able to hear the voices of all thing,
he does not only posses one of the rarest
powers in the story, but his ability to command
the titanic elephant Zunesha suggests that
he holds even greater power still, all on
top of a ridiculously mighty devil fruit.
And I'll even go so far and claim that the
annoyingly perverted side of Momo, that made
me dislike the boy from the very start, was
written on purpose by Oda to give us the most
satisfying development we can get as a reader.
From hate to love.
Because over the course of Wano, Momo has
gained more and more of my respect, and I
can now say that I absolutely love his character.
Which is good, because I've long been subscribed
to the idea that Momo is set up to be one
of the most important characters in the story.
You know, just like you should be to this
channel.
Okay so let's start by addressing the biggest
criticism people have for Momo: His pervertedness.
Which is great, because it's coincidentally
the the secret ingredient to the success of
his character arc.
And you might be thinking now, that I'm giving
Oda too much credit here, and maybe I am,
but hear me out:
Momo's perverted nature differs from that
of Sanji or Brook, which for some people muddies
these otherwise fantastic characters, in that
A, this is a little kid and B, he actually
does the things that Brook and Sanji would
love to, but never could.
This is important, because for Sanji and brook,
Oda clearly thinks it's a funny character
quirk and the fact that Sanji's peep attempts
always end in violence, is supposed to make
it a likable quirk I believe, even if for
some it isn't.
With Momo on the other hand, the smugness
with which he uses his young age to do what
he does, even from Oda's perspective, is clearly
meant to piss you off.
Even if you have no problem with Sanji and
Brook and find their perkiness hilarious,
Momo would annoy you for his smugness.
So in my eyes, this is clearly a trait that
is meant to give us a false first impression
of Momo.
I think Momo actually got this quirk mostly
from the people he grew up with, Kinemon,
Oden, Rayleigh who all are infamous for their
love of women.
When Yamato sticks him inside her shirt to
protect him, he actually doesn't think anything
pervy at all, fully in the process of accepting
his uselessness and preparing to grow as a
character.
The truth here is, that Oda wanted you and
me to dislike Momo from the start, seeing
him as a perverted, spoiled and useless kid,
holding everyone back.
Because his change as a character would be
so much more drastic.
I don't want to exonerate him completely here,
I'm sure he genuinely loves those boobs, but
I also think it's important to consider that
this is an 8 year old who just lost both his
parents as well as his sister mere days ago
and is terribly traumatized when we first
meet him, only we don't know that yet of course.
And so, when he gets to b bath and sleep in
the same bed with Nami and Robin, I think
this is actually Momo looking for some much
needed motherly love rather than anything
else.
What makes Momo's arc so special in retrospect,
not only in One Piece, but in storytelling
overall, is that his development breaks with
two very established tropes.
The typical hero slash shounen arcs are A
that from Boy to man or B that from man to
leader.
Boy to man actually has nothing to do with
age per se, but simply means that a character
needs to leave the nest, question their naive
ideas and learn to face the real world.
Basically a coming of age story.
Usopp falls really nicely into that trope.
The arc from man to leader leader on the other
hand, means that a character goes form being
concerned only for finding a path for himself,
to realizing that he must help others finding
their way as well.
Zoro snd Sanji are great examples of this.
And since I guess you're curious, Luffy's
arc is that from Leader to visionary, going
from helping a few others find the right path
to changing a whole society.
I always loved how these storytelling best
practices explain why One Piece works so wonderfully.
Luffy has the most important arc, but all
other straw hats have their own protagonist
story as well.
Now, you might have already figured out what
makes Momo an odd one out here.
His character arc basically forces him to
combine A and B to go from boy directly to
being a leader.
Momo, despite being a normal kid, is suffocating
under the expectations of an entire oppressed
nation to become the same great leader that
his father used to be, before being executed
days before meeting Luffy.
Talk about a tough spot to be in.
He is still too young to become a man and
far from being the natural leader Luffy is.
And this gives Momo the ultimate arc, to work
his ass off to go through not just one, but
two character changes, way faster and at a
way younger age than most other characters
in One Piece.
And so, once I had the full set of information
available to me in Wano, Momo's arc became
a lot more apparent and interesting.
After losing his parents and being sent into
the future, on top of everything else, he
also gets separated from the only three people
that accompanied him at this point, making
Kanjuro's betrayal the more impactful later
on.
He then survive alone on Punk hazard, with
no time to mourn his dead parents and terrible
fate.
When taken in by the straw hats, he is initially
very distrusting, only revealing his true
identity on Zou after having slowly warming
up to the crew's kindness as well as their
strength.
While he always tries to live according to
all the expectations put on his shoulders,
up until Zou, he basically is a still a traumatized
kid always put in bubble wrap by the retainers.
On Zou, he has his first real moment of character
growth.
After revealing his true identity, he tries
to assume the role of leader, but fails.
[...] Luffy again is the one to teach him
an important lesson in true leadership here.
And so Momo understands what he needs to do
in order to form the big alliance to take
down Kaido and save his country.
Being a leader means being the servant of
your people and not the other way around.
I was also very impressed by the way he handled
Zunesha a bit later, even though suddenly
having a depressed ancient giant elephant
talking to you in your, understandably might
come as a shock for an 8 year old.
Bravo momo.
Now it is on Wano and more specifically Onishima
however, where Momo's arc now comes to full
bloom for me.
At first, it was clear to me, that reaching
his home and facing the aftermath of all the
horrors he had to live through here, was overwhelming
for Momo.
Now that it is actually time for him to assume
his position as leader, he quickly comes to
terms with the fact that he is not the person
everyone wants him to be.
The son of the endlessly charismatic and powerful
Oden.
Momo sinks into self-doubt and leaves most
of the decision making to Luffy and the scabbards.
He feels helplessly pushed around by the events
unfolding throughout the country.
It takes a real shock for momo to come out
of his stupor.
And it is the three most scary events in Wano
so far, that bring out the best in him.
First, he is betrayed and taken Hostage by
Kanjuro, one of the people he had trusted
the most.
And still, instead of feeling defeated, he
starts to fight himself for the first time.
Next, he gets put on a crucifix in front of
the man that killed his father.
And given the option to save his own live,
as a fucking 8 year old kid, he decides to
die for his beliefs and declares himself shogun
anyway, securing him the immediate respect
of all his followers.
Finally, after learning the important role
he has to play from his fathers diary, he
is faced with the prospect of Onigashima crashing
into the flower capital.
And reaching the climax of his arc, he decides
to sacrifice 20 years of his life and his
remaining childhood, and orders Shinobu to
age him to 28.
Another really important moment, as he doesn't
take the scabbards wanting to protect him
as an excuse anymore.
What made this so emotional for me, was that
Momo knows fully well, that this won't change
the fact that he's 8 years at heart, but it
gave him the chance to fight and make a difference.
Flying up and dealing with the problem himself.
The boy has the courage to face all his fears
at once: Heights, Kaido, the responsibility
to lead, and he passes with flying colors.
Watching Luffy has taught him the most important
lesson of all.
You have to take responsibility for what happens
to you, otherwise you will never be able to
change anything.
And so it is actually not surprising that
he not only takes the form of the two men
under whose shadow he had to live until now.
Kaido as a dragon and Oden as a man, finally
prepared to assume his role and surpass them
both as leaders.
Given all of his powers, and whatever is written
about him in his fathers diary, Momo is bound
to be one of the decisive characters once
we reach the end game.
His inspiration after all is Momotaro, the
hero, who got accompanied by a monkey, Luffy,
a dog, Yamato and a pheasant, possibly Aokiji.
All YOU need to understand, is why Luffy was
the only one who could have turned this 8
year old traumatized kid into the next Shogun
of Wano.
And this video will tell exactly why.